welcome back to las vegas now the
following segment is sponsored by
zerorez and now is the perfect time of
year to get your carpets cleaned
take a look july is national carpet
cleaning month so it's a great month to
get your carpets cleaned especially if
you're having some kind of family
function at your house maybe a barbecue
family reunion or even a wedding but
we're in vegas so there's heat so
whatever party is happening
outside will eventually become inside so
uh when it comes to getting your carpets
cleaned we need to go to the experts we
need to go to ben mckee the owner of
zero res
ben welcome to the show how do we know
when it's the right time
to get our carpets clean you know jc i
tell my friends and family all the time
like
if you have pets in your house you need
to have us over about every six months
or in some cases a little more
frequently as you as we know
um if you've got if you've got kids or
family who's struggling with allergies
give us a call if you've got you know an
event coming up you have spots or stains
that keep reappearing from the other
guys
who are cleaning your carpets gives your
res a shot we can fix all these things
for you
and get your carpets looking uh just as
good as new again
let's talk about what you guys use you
use zr water tell everyone
what zr water is and the magic that the
zr water does to your carpets
so zr water we take our wonderful las
vegas water that we have
and we filter it we run it through a
softener and we've sent it through this
electrolysis process that
raises its ph and it gives the water
this incredible cleaning power
that's completely safe and it's it's
really the most effective cleaning
technology on the market today
and it allows us to clean your carpets
without soaps and surfactants
and we all know what those do those
those leave behind the crunchy sticky
residue in our carpets
as zero red you don't have that problem
you're left with just clean carpets that
stay cleaner longer
and bend you mentioned pets earlier we
are in the middle of the dog days of
summer and as a pet owner i'm sure other
pet owners
can agree probably the one major issue
or maybe two major issues when it comes
to owning pets is
when they have an accident and there's a
stain and there's an odor so
how do you guys tackle this issue so we
have an
arsenal of products that can safely
break down
uh you know whatever product it is
whether it's you know urine or
other biological issues we can get it
cleaned up and we can make it
we can make that stain go away and we're
not just covering it up with you know
deodorizers and things like that we're
actually removing it
so it's safe and hygienic and looks
great you have over
15 000 positive reviews online
how does it make you guys feel our team
loves from our technicians to me to our
call center
we just love making people happy and we
love the raving reviews that we have and
we couldn't do it without our awesome
community here in las vegas
and you have a partnership right now
with cowabunga bay tell everybody about
it
we do right now if we're going to give
out some free tickets to cowabunga bay
you can get your carpets clean and go
cool off in this crazy heat that we're
having
and it's an incredible time to get
cleaned and we we love cowabunga bay and
i should go there later today or
something let's do it you know
when we wrap this up let's go over there
and go to calabanga bay
zerorez has a big july special for
national carpet cleaning month
get three rooms of carpets clean for
only 99
plus get two free passes to cowabunga
bay
call 702-840-3333 or visit xerorez
lasvegas.com
minimums apply rocky over to you